certainly powerful to see all the
players locking arms and uh you know the
landscape that we're at right now the
the sense of unity that we're seeing
across all sports especially right now
major league baseball really important
to have this first base runner of the
night two out single and kyle seeger
will be the next batter there goes lewis
pitch on the way swinging a miss and
strike three and that will retire the
side so trout gets a board with two down
here in the bottom of the first chopped
softly on the left side charging a
seeger will have to hurry this throw and
he gets it to first base in time the
umpires are going to get together this
might be a foul ball it to me it sounded
like it hit twice at home plate hit
twice
hit twice off the bat it goes down comes
back up hits it again this is foul ball
so everything is back to normal trout
leads uh first two outs here's the
one-two pitch and this is chopped right
to the short stop it's fielded by
crawford he will flip to second so two
outs for the angels here in the bottom
half of the second castronell with a
chance to drive in that first run of the
game swing at a miss and a slider down
on the way for strike three that is
strikeout number three for nick margaret
runners everywhere
and here is rendon with a chance to do
some serious damage that smash hit the
short they're going to turn two on this
one and
they will get out of the inning that was
a taylor made double play ball hit right
at crawford to be haney's 50th pitch of
the game there's a swing of the miss a
fastball he got him struck him out
strong inning for hiney a couple
strikeouts in the inning for andrew
heaney and in the ball game
heaney now has recorded five one on one
away no score top of the fifth and
here's second baseman chad long chasing
that breaking ball that was a real good
slider good depth to it and it was never
going to be in the strike zone she got
him to swing at your pitch
coming into the game 21 and 28 lifetime
and there's a swing of the missing to
change up and he struck him out paris
strikeouts for hiney in the last two
innings
to have a runner in scoring position
right away in this scoreless top of the
sixth and that brings up sam hagerty
swing this is a ground ball up the
middle it's in a center field for a base
hit j.p crawford is getting waved in
trout has no throw home
and sam hagerty a nine-game hit streak
now has put the mariners in front first
run of the ball game it's one to nothing
in the sixth inning so here's seeger
getting ready to bet a little check
swing a roller on the left side tough
play for rendon throws albert scoops it
out of the dirt and they get him nice
play by rindell two down and looking at
albert pole she's so comfortable at
first base with those scoops runner in
scoring position with two outs the tying
run is at second here comes albert
pujols that's pulled toward the left
field corner and that is a fair ball
extra base hit for albert it's a devil
and an rbi and we're tied up at one what
this is a rocket down in that left field
corner short hops the wall
hits off the foul pole but
for albert he did not miss this one so
here's upton at the plate he's already
had a couple hits tonight he pulls this
one through the hole a three-hit game
albert's gonna be waved around here
comes the throw from lopes to the plate
it's way off line and got upton in a run
down here the angels will take a 2-1
lead as we head to the seventh inning
the go-ahead rbi single score in albert
pools
andrew heaney is back out there he's at
94 pitches he's been sensational in this
game realistically only four hits for
seattle in this game tonight here's sam
hegarty called strike three top part of
the strike zone he will leave the game
setting down the final six batters he
faced drown a single intentional walk
and a strikeout one for two skies one
out toward left center field towering
shot kyle lewis near the wall that is
gone
big fly for mike trout his 11th of the
season and extends the angels lead just
got it over the center fielder kyle
lewis went back and at the last moment
just watched it leave a towering home
run for trout you knew it was high
enough it was whether or not it was deep
enough and he got it over the wall
takes the lead off oh for three time
buttress still in the game
he hits this one well into the gap
that'll get down one hop off the fence
saw a lead off doubled by kyle seeger
singer with his 10th double of this
season but tree has gotten into a little
bit of trouble here in this ninth inning
a pair on one out
and lopes will be the next batter he
shoots this one down the right fulan
it's a fair ball seeger is going to be
waved around adele's throws going toward
third marmalajos the relay to third base
got him simba unbelievable and that was
the tying run that would have been its
third base with one away now two outs
here in the ninth long pops it up
shallow left brian goodwood
coming on should do it and the halo will
shine tonight as the angels pick up the
victory by the final of three to two
well played game today it started off
with this
emotional powerful moment